our writer John blitt loves JD loves
having adventures with JD yes they make
a good pair because John is up for
anything and JD is up for nothing so
there you go I don't know how JD keeps
going out with John black he is fun but
uh and a good guy but uh you know
there's also the the devilish side of
him that can get annoying sometimes and
you have to like it because he loves me
hold on I do love blit I do
I do like there is a sure there is a
part of me that likes to be
um uh taken out of my comfort zone and
experience new things or whatever okay
John organized a surprise trip for them
to the 10th Street Russian and Turkish
baths John thought this would get JD out
of his comfort zone and make for some
good radio he was not wrong this Bath
House JD knows offers several spa
treatments right JD oh yeah it consists
of a steam room saunas a radiant heat
room and a cold plunge pool you use the
smart strategy I have to commend you for
this you didn't tell JD ahead of time
where you were taking him nope I do not
like surprises at all and I wanted to
take JD like with my on my first year
working at the show I was wanting to
take JD to this just for his body and
his mind and his yes JD did not react
well when he finally figured out where
John was taking him he freaked out here
here he realizes he's going to a bath
house if it's a [__] Russian bath
house really pissed yeah it's okay
[__] pissed yeah because he [__]
pitched that to me [__] five years
ago and I said no
and I knew that's exactly what this was
gonna be I knew it I knew that's what
this was
so the first stop the first stop at the
bath house was the Russian heat room
Robin this is heated by a wood oven to
approximately 240 degrees and what do
you think happened JD was not happy
let me tell you Howard I have been there
you can't imagine how hot these rooms
are yeah and guess who hates heat JD
the hissing you're hearing is the steam
coming out
I'll see you oh my God Jesus [__]
inside the door's hot God oh boy I can't
handle this dude just relax get into it
the [__] Wood's gonna be hot you
could do a good dump I don't want to do
a dump let me see you do a donkey
yeah I don't want that I don't want that
I don't like that at all I don't like
that don't try it no I don't want to try
the dunk you're referring to is uh when
you get too hot you fill a bucket with
cold water and pour it on yourself to
cool down is that the idea yeah yeah and
JD did a little one I gave him a little
dunk and it helped him stay there
multiple dunks first yeah you're good
that's the sound of enjoyment that was
the sound of JD's pleasure that was not
pleasant first of all I felt my I
thought my skin was gonna burn off right
which is that's a good thing that's why
you go to the baths to feel the heat and
to feel your skin burn you know JD
prolific sweater anyway
you know thank you Robin JD just walking
down the street
dressed in the summertime how's he
supposed to survive this after the hot
room the boys had a plaza where a
massage specialist hits your entire body
with a bundle of leaves and twigs I was
going to ask if he got the fronds yes
because these are the long long branches
and they try to beat the crap out of you
well the plaza must have relaxed JD
because he started talking about the
first time he orgasmed while getting his
massage
oh my god do you remember your first
time having an orgasm yes
it was oh God I forget how old I was but
I somehow got a hold of condom so my
friend got condoms or something so he
gave me one
and I was trying to I wanted to see like
in case uh I did uh end up with a girl I
wanted to seem sort of like know what I
was doing so I
practiced putting on a condom on and
when I put the condom on I that's when I
orgasm right were you stroking yourself
or did you not really no it was just it
was a crazy sensation and it just
happened so I'm like oh okay the guy
asked me if I wanted to take my shirt
off for this I said no and then what I
said I said go easy go easy because I
knew they'd beat the [__] out of me or
do God knows what when I said I wanted
to keep my shirt on he gave me like a
look like oh God JD you really opened up
you were getting hit with those leaves I
could hear the leaves bashing into your
body and he's not stuttering do you hear
this is a constant stream of words with
no interruption he's completely
understandable this is amazing JD when
the spa day was over John blitt rewarded
JD with a trip to the rooftop Terrace
for some beer authentic Russian food and
the joint JD enjoyed all the Russian
food except for a dish called Kasha
which is roasted buckwheat he thought it
was too dry and John now John started
name with JD John says to JD I think you
just you should tell the chef that the
food is too dry
you like Kasha oh very dry can you get
the chef please
get the chef no don't stop let's get the
chef can you get the chef please stop
it's a good idea no it's not if you
think it's dry you should say something
but it's I don't like this no get it
stop I mean I swear to God well done you
have to tell people that you don't like
the food those are my favorite things
you do with JD when you just say oh this
is unacceptable JD I'm gonna have the
chef come right up here so you can tell
them the food's too dry and it always
works no matter what
and the thing is if he starts believing
me then I'm gonna go and get the chef
and have him come to JD
JD had a final take on the bath house
experience and here it is great uh
banyang thank you for enlightening me
I'll never do this again no you will no
no I won't I think you will no I can
tell you I'm not you have to
once a year once a year once a year no
shut up okay cheers to once a year
cheers no
cheers for this one time a year
there it is a big adventure JD and John
blitt